hello I'm Jude Law and I'm Eddie
Redmayne and it has been a minute since
you were last at the Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry so we are taking
you back to school
old school go ahead ridiculous before I
look like that I look like this Wow the
crimes of Greenville introduces
audiences to Hogwarts before the Boy Who
Lived it's good to be back
God love her boards it's exactly the
same nothing's changed
no still floating candles it was a time
when dark wizard Gellert Grindelwald
with rising to power and there was only
one wizard who could stand in his way
Albus Dumbledore not true Newt Scamander
two wizards Albus Dumbledore secretly
teams art with noose commander to take
on Grendel volt but compass might be
hiding some secrets of his own
mysterious I've got a few tricks up my
sleeve well you got me child already oh
stop it
join Jude now as we hang out in the old
hog as the beloved words of Harry Potter
a fantastic piece continued to build
upon their magical connections in the
crimes occur in the world in theaters
this November
well done what student has become the
head mask laughs you've actually you
become the headmaster the IAA right have
you read books I have honestly
[Music]